The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So last time, there
was a question that was asked
about the order of
magnitude rates.
You asked the question
about the
concentration of the catalysts.
So the rates that I gave you,
which were the rates of
reactions are basically
order of magnitude.
They're estimates and odd
numbers that, they obviously
depend, as you pointed out,
depend on the concentration of
the catalyst.
Depends on the concentration
of the reactants.
Depends on where you are on
those concentrations.
As we saw when we did enzyme
catalysis, is that depending
on KM, the Michaelis constant,
and the substrate
concentration, if your
substrate's concentration is
much higher than KM, you are in
the maximum velocity limit,
where the rate depends on
k2 times the initial
concentration of enzyme.
In that case the rate of the
reaction depends just on the
concentration of enzyme,
and not on the
concentration of substrate.
But if you are at the small
concentration of substrate
relative to KM, then your rate
depends linearly with the
concentration of substrate.
And the same thing happens
with the non-enzymatic
catalyst, that there will be
some sort of mechanism that
goes along with it.
And most likely it's
going to be second
order in the catalyst.
And the reactant if it's just
the two body process.
But it could be more
complicated.
So definitely those
concentrations will go in there.
But a priori, it's not clear
how they will go in there.
But the orders of magnitude
are roughly right.
And the basic idea is that you
change your rate of reactions
by 15, 18 orders of magnitude
with the right catalyst,
especially if it's a biological
catalyst.
One concept that I didn't go
through last time, which is
also quite useful, it's called
the turnover number.
Turnover number.
And this is useful for
any kind of catalyst.
But for enzymatic, or enzyme
catalysts, the
turnover number is k cat.
The number per second.
It's a rate per second.
How many times does a reactant
get, the number of times that
a reactant turns into a product
per second, per catalyst.
So let me write it out.
So it's the number of product
formed per second, per second,
per enzyme, per molecule
of enzyme.
OK, so if one enzyme is going to
be there, there's going to
be some substrate going in.
Coming in, the pocket
coming out.
Coming in, the pocket coming
out, so the number of cycles
of this process per second.
is the turnover number.
And so if you are where the
concentration of substrate is
very much larger than the
Michaelis constant, where are
you are at the saturation limit,
then this turnover
number doesn't depend on the
substrate concentration.
It's just k cat.
So that's why k cat
is important.
As this turnover number in the
maximum velocity limit.
Because in the maximum velocity
limit, then the
process that's dominant is the
second process, ES goes to
enzyme plus product.
The first process here is not
the rate limiting step.
This is the rate
limiting step.
Because the substrate
concentration is very high.
So this first part goes very
high, goes very fast.
And the number of product
formed per second, per
molecule of enzyme, the number
of molecules formed for
second, that's the rate
of product formation.
Rate of product formation
per second.
Divided by the concentration
of the enzyme.
If you normalize by the
number of enzyme.
So this becomes rate of product
formation in moles per
second, divided by
moles of enzyme.
It's the same thing as what
we're saying here in words.
And so the rate of product
formation is dP/dt, and you
divide that by the concentration
of enzyme, which
you can write as E0. dp/dt,
and the maximum
rate limit is k max.
It's a constant divided by E0.
And k max is k cat times
E0 divided by E0.
The E0's come out.
And this is k cat.
Which is basically k2.
So that's the turnover number.
Any questions on this
turnover number?
You see that a lot in catalyst
literature and
especially the enzymes.
I have to get out these
lecture notes.
Send these back.
OK, so the last topic
I want to talk about
is oscillating reactions.
It's sort of like an
interesting topic.
And it's applicable not just
to just chemistry, but it's
basically playing with the
differential equations.
And you'll see this sort of
stuff later if you keep doing
science that involves coupled
differential equations.
It's just all over the place.
So normally we have an
equilibrium process.
A goes to B, B goes back to A.
And if you start out with
something which is out of
equilibrium, then you will
eventually reach equilibrium at
a rate which is dependent
on those two rates. k1
plus k minus one.
So B will to come up to
some B equilibrium.
And A will, if you start out
with a lot of A, and a little
bit of B, and concentration of
A, will come down smoothly,
monotonically, to the
equilibrium state.
But sometimes, if you're out
of equilibrium, and this
doesn't have to be chemistry.
It could be anything that's
out of equilibrium, your
emotion's out of equilibrium.
Stock market is out
of equilibrium.
Population dynamics are
out of equilibrium.
The weather.
Whatever.
So, you're out of equilibrium,
let's say this is equilibrium
for A, this is equilibrium for
B, let me try to keep them
somewhat the same as
here, I messed up.
You're out of equilibrium, you
start down here for A. And
you, instead of going linearly
down or monotonically down,
exponentially down to the
equilibrium, instead you overshoot.
And you keep going
back and forth.
Like a spring.
And then B does the
same thing.
Overshoots, comes down.
Like a pendulum.
A lot of things work
like that.
The heart is something that
works like that, right?
It beats.
It's not in equilibrium.
Good thing it's not
in equilibrium.
So the heart is one example of
something that oscillates,
back and forth, back
and forth.
And so there are actually many
examples of complicated
processes that involve
chemistry, that aren't at
equilibrium, that instead go
back and forth, in and out, of
on one side or the other
of equilibrium.
Now, there's an important
feature of, if you want to
build a chemical process
that looks like this.
It's often very useful to have
a particular step in the
mechanism that's called
an autocatalysis step.
And that provides feedback.
It's like, if my microphone
here, the speaker which is
here, I were to stand right in
front of the speaker and my
microphone would pick up the
volume from the speaker, it
would get amplified,
and I get feedback.
And that would be a bad thing.
So this is a form of
feedback here.
You need some sort of feedback
that the reaction knows that
you're building up, that
this is going too fast.
And then there's a feedback
process that
brings it back up.
And a feedback process that
goes back and forth.
And the way you get this
feedback is by having a step
in the mechanism that has both
a molecule as part of the
reactants and as part
of the product.
It's not the same as a chain
reaction, where we talked
about an intermediate being
recycled and building up.
This is an actual reactant and
an actual product that's part
of this step here.
So this is an autocatalytic
step.
And let's just see what
that step looks like.
Suppose we just have
that step.
So we want to find out, as a
function of time, if you start
out with some A and B, what
happens to the concentration
of B as a function of time.
The time dependence of that.
Clearly it's going
to build up.
But how is it going
to build up?
So we need to solve for B
as a function of time.
So let's go ahead and write
down our rates.
The rate of the reaction is
d[A]/dt, is, let's put a rate
constant here. k, k times
[A] times [B].
Now, [B] and [A]
are related to each other
through stoichiometry.
The concentration of B is the
concentration of B that he
started out with, [B]0, then
every time you destroy an A,
you create 2B.
So it's plus two times the
amount of A that you've
destroyed, [A]0 minus
[A], [A]0 is what
you started out with.
This is what's left over.
So the difference is what
you've destroyed.
But every time you destroy
an A to form 2B, you
also destroy a b.
So you have to subtract away the
B that you've destroyed.
Which is [A]0 minus [A].
This is the 2B that you created
by destroying A, and
this is the B that you destroy
by having to destroy A, for
the reaction.
You've got to bean-count
correctly.
Keep track of everything.
So [B], then, is just, I'm going
to drop those brackets.
B0 plus A0 minus A. So you
can plug that in here.
And is equal to k times A, times
B0 plus B0 minus A. And
now you have a differential
equation that only
contains A and time.
B0 is a constant.
And the way you solve that
is by partial fractions.
Use partial fractions,
solve for this.
And I'm not going to
go through the math
of solving for it.
It's not that interesting.
Let me give you the answer.
You end up with [B] as a
function of time, is this
function A0 plus B0 over one
plus A0 over B0 times e to the
minus k times A0 plus
B0 plus time.
And that's where the time
component comes in.
Whoops, I'm sorry.
Usually I don't have this
on, let's turn this off.
That's where the time
dependence comes in.
And clearly, at t is equal to
infinity, t equals infinity
just goes to zero.
So you have B as A0, plus B0,
everything goes through to the
product. t equals to zero,
this is equal to one.
And B is equal to just B0.
Alright, and so the curve looks
something like this.
This is what it turns
out to look like.
We're starting with B0 here.
There's an induction period
where very little happens.
It's like the dormant stage.
So, locusts that are sitting
in the ground for seventeen
years waiting for something
to happen.
Dormant stage, the
induction period.
And suddenly something
starts to happen.
There's an inflection point.
And you get to A0 plus B0.
The locusts wake up.
And go to maximum
concentration.
So there's an s-like shape that
has an inflection point
and an induction period.
That's pretty typical of an
auto-catalytic reaction.
OK so let's apply it
to a process now.
And again, this is going
to be coupled
differential equations.
Broadly, broadly applicable,
the example that I'm
going to give you.
This mechanism has been used
for all sorts of things.
So what do we have here?
We're going to have an island.
In the ocean.
Island here.
And it's going to be sunny,
so let's get some
yellow chalk here.
There's the sun.
And every now and then
it's going to rain.
We need some white chalk
for the rain.
There's a cloud that comes in.
That's going to be one
of the reactants.
And then some seeds blow in from
the continent, and grass
starts to grow on the island.
Grass.
And then there's a shipwreck and
a couple of rabbits get on
the island.
And now we have rabbits.
Rabbits.
A little tail on the back.
I hate rabbits.
I have a little vegetable
garden, a little tiny
vegetable garden.
And there are rabbits.
And I have to fence in my
vegetable garden and make it
impermeable impenetrable
to rabbits.
And rabbits are very clever.
And my vegetable garden
looks like a fortress.
It's got a green fence.
Heavy duty things.
It's terrible.
Rabbits are awful.
They're very cute but
they're awful.
Alright, so now what happens.
Well, given the rain and the
grass, it turns out that this
island can only support
25 rabbits.
If there are more rabbits
than that, then
they all eat too much.
If there are less rabbits
then that's fine.
But 25 is about the
maximum that can
support on this island.
The rabbits, unfortunately,
are not that smart.
They don't know that.
They don't know that only 25
rabbits can live there.
So, what happens is that the
Year one, Year one there are
ten rabbits.
And the food condition
is great.
Lots of food, number
of rabbits.
Lots of food.
So the bunnies, the rabbits
make bunnies.
Lots of rabbits.
Year two, they kind
of went overboard.
Now there are 50 rabbits.
The food is lousy.
Terrible.
Well, there's a feedback here.
Feedback and rabbits
start to die off.
Don't reproduce as much.
Year three, we're back to ten.
Great food.
Rabbits don't notice.
They multiply.
Food is terrible.
And they just don't learn.
Humans are a little
bit like that.
Except our cycle isn't one
year, it's usually on the
order of 30 years.
It's like the memory of a
generation disappearing.
And we have to relearn the
mistakes of the previous
generation.
Science is like that too.
Science goes in cycles.
20, 30-year cycles.
Topics that were out of fashion
20 years ago, 25 years
ago, come back.
And suddenly everybody's
excited about them.
And all the ideas, of course
we make progress.
We go a little bit further
than we did 20 years ago.
But all the ideas that were
out of fashion 20
years ago come back.
People get really excited, and
they relearn all the mistakes
that people made at
the beginning.
Technology has improved, we know
more, and therefore we go
a little bit further this
cycle than we did
the previous cycle.
But it's really interesting to
look at history of science and
see this sort of cycle.
So let's write a mechanism.
Let's write a mechanism here.
So we have rain plus grass
makes more grass.
At the rate k1.
That's autocatalytic.
It provides some feedback.
Then we have grass plus rabbits
make more rabbits.
OK, let's do more because
I don't know
how much, more, more.
Also autocatalytic.
Then we have rabbits.
Eventually, unfortunately,
rabbits become dead rabbits.
Rate k2 k3, and that's the
termination of the process.
OK, so now let's put some
chemistry on this.
Let's assume that instead of
having objects, live objects
here, we have chemical
molecules.
So A plus B goes to 2B.
That's the first step.
Then we have B plus C,
C is the rabbits.
And then C goes to some
sort of products.
Soil.
This is a very famous
mechanism.
It's called the Lotka-Volterra
It's also called the
predator-prey mechanism.
In my case here, I made it
sort of warm and fuzzy.
I didn't have a predator
in there.
But you could change this.
Instead of having rabbits
and grass, we could
have rabbits and foxes.
Where A is the grass, if you
take A to be the grass.
B to be the rabbits.
And C you be the foxes.
Works the same.
You have grass plus rabbits
makes more rabbits.
Rabbit plus foxes
make more foxes.
Eventually the foxes die off.
Same idea.
So now, let's solve this.
Let's assume that A, the rain
here, it's constant.
There's a steady
supply of rain.
It doesn't go away.
That makes sense in
my example here.
So the concentration of
A is kept constant.
In order to get oscillations to
keep going, that turns out
to be important.
To have one of the reactants
just keeping being
reintroduced in the system.
Because it gets used up.
And when all the reactant gets
used up, then you're done.
So in the case of the heart,
we have to keep feeding
ourselves to produce energy.
Otherwise the heart
would stop.
OK, now we want to know what is
the concentration of B and
C as a function of time.
So we write down our kinetic
equations. dB/dt gets produced
through the first step, k1 A
times B, gets destroyed in the
second step. k2 B times C.
dC/dt, C gets produced in the
second step, k2 B times C. Gets
destroyed in the third
step. k3 times C, got to do your
bean-counting correctly.
And the strategy here that we're
going to use to solve
the problem is to assume that
we're at steady state.
We're going to find the solution
at steady state.
Then we're going to perturb
away from steady state a
little bit.
And see whether this creates
an oscillation.
First we need to find out what
the steady state solution is.
So first, let's find
steady state.
Then perturb away from
We're looking at a harmonic
response, if
you've heard that term.
When it's going to look like
a spring, close to its
equilibrium state.
That means that we're going to
set it these two things equal
to zero, for this
steady state.
Things are not changing.
Concentration of B and
C are not changing.
A is not changing
on purpose here.
And so all these guys here
are then steady state
concentrations.
If we set it equal to zero.
We solve for A in this.
For C in this process here.
The B's cancel out here.
We divide by B. And you solve
for C as a function of A. So
this one here gives you C steady
state is equal to k1
over k2 times the concentration
of A. And this
one here, now you put in the C
and you solve for B, B steady
state, is equal to k3 over k2.
So the next step is to perturb
away from equilibrium.
Or from the steady
state, rather.
This is not equilibrium, it's
not equilibrium because we
keep adding A. We have to put
some input into the system.
So here we are.
We've got some concentration of
B here at the steady state.
We have some concentration
of C at the steady state.
And now we're going to add some
delta B to the system, or
delta C. Or both.
Delta C, we're going to ask the
question, given our system
here, how is it going
to respond?
It has a number of choices.
It could respond by going back
to the steady state in a
monotonic fashion.
Without overshooting.
This is kind of like an
overdamped system.
It's like having a shock
absorber on your car.
You go over a bump, the car
doesn't oscillate up and down.
It's sort of damped.
It's a damped oscillator.
It goes back to the
steady state.
Or, you could, there we go,
there's B, C. Or you could
perturb, and it could just
stay where it is.
That could happen too.
That's an inelastic response.
Kind of like the supply
and demand with oil.
The price of oil goes from $10
a barrel to $120 a barrel.
The use of oil doesn't seem to
be affected very much by the
increasing price.
You're still using
just as much oil.
There's an inelastic response.
What we're looking for is
something that has an elastic
response, or a harmonic
response.
We perturb it, it tries to
get back to steady state.
But because of feedback, and not
being over-damped, if it's
an oscillator, it goes
up and down.
Like a scale that is not well,
well, like a car that has bad
shock absorbers, all it
has is the springs.
Up and down.
So what we want is, we want
to solve for dB/dt as
a function of time.
We want, well, I'm going to
do everything in green.
Since I lost my white chalk.
We want delta B, delta C
as a function of time.
So, that means that we start
with B is B steady state plus
delta B, C is C steady state
plus delta C. And we put that
in our equations.
For dB/dt and dC/dt.
So now dB/dt is the same thing
as dB steady state plus delta
B dt, which is d delta B / dt.
Because this is a
constant here.
And that's equal to k1 times A,
times B steady state plus
delta B. Minus k2 times B steady
state plus delta B
times C steady state plus delta
C. And then you have the
same thing for dC/dt, it's
going to look exactly
identical. d delta C / dt.
Thank you much, this is magic.
k2 times B steady state plus
delta B, times C steady state
plus delta C, minus k3 times C
steady state plus delta C.
So these are two differential
equations.
And there are coupled
differential equations.
Because delta B is occurring
here, here, and here.
So the time derivative of delta
C depends on delta B.
And the time derivative of delta
B depends on delta C.
It's a coupled system.
And if you actually expand this
out and take away all the
terms that cancel out, you end
up with something that looks
much simpler but is just as
hard. d delta B / dt is equal
to minus k3 delta C and d delta
C / dt is equal to k1 A
delta B.
And then you really see that
it's coupled, because the time
derivative of delta B depends
on delta C. And the time
derivative of delta C depends
on delta B. And there's the
feedback sitting right here.
And that's what you do.
You learn how to
solve in 18.03.
So I'm not going to solve it
here, I'm just going to give
you the solutions.
Because that's what we're
interested in.
After all, you're not expected
to learn how
to solve this equation.
Although you should be able to
put the solutions in and make
sure that they do work out.
And so the solutions are
harmonic solutions.
Delta B is a function of time
is equal to delta B0.
The amount of the perturbation
times the cosine of omega t,
where omega is the frequency
of the oscillation.
Minus some pre-factor here, k3
over k1 A to the 1/2 power.
Times delta C0 sine
of omega t.
And then delta C
looks the same.
The same frequency.
Delta C0, cosine of omega t.
Plus k1 over A times k3
to the 1/2 power.
Delta B0 sine of omega t, where
omega, the frequency of
the oscillation, is these
rates. k1, k3 and A. So
obviously, keeping the
concentration of a constant is
important because we don't want
a time dependence here.
The rain is constant.
And then if you do that, then
you have this oscillation.
Up and down and up and down
with this frequency here.
You get exactly what we're
trying to get.
Which is this process
right here.
So let me give you an
example of this.
And the best way to do is to
actually go and see a movie of
a reaction that looks
like this.
This is the reaction that was
optimized and created for
demonstration purposes.
So it's a pretty complicated
reaction.
There are ten steps
to the mechanism.
And if we gave you that
mechanism to solve for the
final exam, you would still
be here probably
two weeks form now.
It's pretty complicated.
You'd need a computer
for sure.
So, ten steps, well, that's
what's known.
There are probably
more than that.
It's probably more complicated
than what we really know in
terms of fishing out
intermediates.
And the basic reaction is, you
start out with an oxide of
iodine, which is clear.
You create I2, which is
going to look gold.
In solution, and then it creates
Ii minus, which is
going to look deep blue.
And then it'll feed back
and start again.
So we're going to have this
cycle of products.
And amongst those ten steps, or
more than ten steps, there
are a few autocatalytic steps,
which provide the feedback.
So now I have to start it.
Let's go ahead and read.
Alright.
So here we go.
So, there are two solutions, A
and solution C. Actually, we
mix three solutions together.
The potassium iodide is what is
going to give rise to the
different colors.
And now we're in the gold
phase of the reaction.
It's important to stir,
otherwise it wouldn't, and
then it turns deep blue.
And then there's an induction
period, where
you wait for a while.
And then eventually it
should go clear.
So it goes clear.
And then it turns gold again.
And then deep blue, and there's
the oscillation.
And then a long induction
period, and then it goes
through that cycle over
and over again.
And the recipe can be
found pretty easily.
And if you ever are in a lab,
have access to doing this,
it's a pretty easy reaction
to put together.
The only problem is that unless
you use fresh hydrogen
peroxide, it doesn't work.
Because hydrogen peroxide tends
to go bad over time.
If you're going to do this,
buy your hydrogen peroxide
immediately before you try
to do the experiment.
And then it'll work.
So what happens is that as
long as there is a steady
supply of hydrogen peroxide in
here, it'll keep oscillating.
But as you've used up the
hydrogen peroxide, this is
going to start to die.
And eventually it'll have
this pale blue solution.
And it's like the
heart stopping.
If you want to start it up
again, add more hydrogen
peroxide and it'll
start up again.
OK, any questions?
There's like an infinite number
of these oscillating
reactions that people
have discovered.
And optimized, that you can
find in different places.
Questions?
Questions about the final.
I didn't get to do a review,
but you'll get that
done with the TAs.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Because there's
enough of the equivalent of A,
of the rain here.
So it'll oscillate and there'll
be some damping.
So what will happen in this
reaction is that the induction
period will get longer, and
longer, and longer.
Because the w, this term right
here, the frequency which
depends on the concentration
of A, that well
get slower and slower.
And eventually it'll just die.
OK?